-On vient d'apprendre
qu'il y avait une famille
remise à la rue,
qui avait une solution
jusqu'à samedi
et qui repart à la rue samedi
dans la journée...
-D'accord.
-...qui était hébergée
chez des particuliers,
et qui a pas de solution.
Avec des enfants,
avec trois enfants,
donc on va chercher une solution.
On a une cagnotte
pour les héberger le week-end,
mais ça va partir très vite,
avec les hôtels à Lyon.
-On aimerait ne pas
arriver au point
où il faudrait un mort dans la rue
pour que l'Etat se bouge
pour débloquer des places.
Et là, vous faites du mieux
que vous pouvez
pour mettre à l'abri
des enfants,
mais on bricole
avec des bouts de ficèle.
J'essaie d'avoir
la banderole en entier.
Je suis Marie-Charlotte Guérin,
députée écologiste.
On est devant une école
dans laquelle dorment des enfants
qui dorment à la rue
en temps normal.
On alerte le gouvernement
sur le besoin de places
d'hébergement d'urgence
pour qu'on n'ait plus 2822 enfants
qui dorment dehors en France.
Brouhaha
-Un euro, s'il te plaît.
-Merci !
-C'est lequel,
le gâteau que t'as fait ?
-Celui-là.
-Je vais goûter ton gâteau,
s'il en reste.
-Cela devient une habitude
pour Marie-Charlotte Guérin :
quand la députée arrive
dans sa circonscription,
direction l'école,
où des goûters solidaires
s'organisent.
-Il y a plein de parents mobilisés,
il y a des non-parents.
-Les parentes d'élèves
ont appris que trois enfants
de l'école dormaient
dans la rue.
Alors une solidarité s'installe
pour les aider.
-Si on est en galère ce week-end,
on sait qu'on a ce matelas,
cette respiration, pour pouvoir
les loger à l'hôtel.
Mais ça suffira jamais
pour tous les week-ends de l'année.
-Ce soir-là,
360 euros
auront été récoltés.
Une cagnotte utile
car le numéro
du SAMU social est saturé
par les demandes.
-Les familles, elles appellent
tous les jours le 115,
et tous les jours...
-Les chiffres sont catastrophiques,
sur le 115.
En fait, c'est pas
le taux de réponses
mais de solutions trouvées.
En fait, sur 1600-1700 appels,
la semaine du 2 au 8 octobre,
t'en as 1200
qui sont sans solutions.
C'est le cas tous les jours.
Nous, à côté de ça,
en tant que parlementaires,
on se sent hyper impuissants.
Ca craque de tous les côtés,
tout le monde est à bout,
que ça soit vous, parents d'élèves,
qui occupez et bouleversez
vos vies de famille pour faire
marcher la solidarité locale,
que ce soit la ville
qui essaie mais qui a pas
toutes les compétences,
ou les travailleurs sociaux,
tout le monde craque.
-Pour désengorger le 115,
le gouvernement
annonce la création
de 500 postes supplémentaires
au SAMU social.
A Lyon,
330 enfants passent
leurs journées à l'école
et leurs nuits dans la rue,
des enfants
en grande majorité étrangers,
le plus souvent
en situation irrégulière.
En France, même s'il n'a pas
de papiers,
un mineur a le droit
d'être scolarisé.
-La question de la crise
de l'hébergement d'urgence
est le résultat
de deux crises parallèles.
D'un côté, une crise de l'accueil :
on n'accueille pas correctement.
De l'autre, une crise
du logement tout court.
Donc on se retrouve
à pallier à l'urgence.
C'est des enfants à la rue.
Quand on dit qu'il faut des places
d'hébergement d'urgence,
on ne résout aucune crise,
mais c'est ce qu'il faut faire.
-La députée a invité
la presse locale
pour faire témoigner
Hanane, une maman de l'école qui,
il y a encore quelques mois,
dormait dans la rue.
-Tchou-tchou !
-Oui, après ?
-Cette Algérienne a fui son pays
avec son fils,
aujourd'hui en classe de CE2.
-Comment tu t'es senti
quand t'as dormi dans la rue ?
-Difficile.
-Difficile, un peu froid.
On peut pas manger.
On peut pas faire pipi,
on peut pas faire caca.
On peut pas faire les devoirs.
-J'ai dormi à la rue
pendant quelques mois,
et après, j'ai dormi
dans l'école de mon fils
pendant presque deux mois.
Quand je dormais à la rue,
j'avais peur pour mon fils et moi,
parce que c'est difficile.
-Maman, c'est quoi, ça ?
-Depuis la rentrée, Hanane
et Nordine logent
dans un hébergement d'urgence
jusqu'à septembre prochain.
Dans le gymnase
de l'école où Hanane et Nordine
ont également dormi,
une autre famille
a trouvé refuge.
Chaque soir, grâce à la mairie,
ces trois enfants
de 9 ans, 6 ans et 6 mois
s'installent
dans un confort sommaire.
Marie-Charlotte Guérin
a décidé de dormir avec eux.
-J'ai mon pyjama, ma trousse
de toilette et ma gourde,
donc le minimum.
-La députée
est venue avec son sac à dos
et s'est occupée du dîner.
A table, elle fait connaissance
avec la famille.
-Tu mets un peu de riz ?
T'as une belle assiette, là.
Vous travaillez, Mohamed ?
-Oui.
-Vous faites quoi ?
-Là, on vient pour voir
ce que vous vivez au quotidien
parce qu'il y a pas
de bon hébergement dehors,
il y a pas de logement dehors.
Et...
Moi, c'est une nuit,
et il y a des gens pour qui
c'est plusieurs semaines.
Vous, ça fait depuis combien,
on a dit ?
-Cinq semaines.
-Marie-Charlotte Guérin
milite pour une augmentation
des places d'hébergement d'urgence.
Dans le projet de loi de finances,
la députée avait déposé
deux amendements transpartisans,
soutenus par la gauche,
le centre et la majorité,
pour la création
de 10 000 places supplémentaires.
D'abord adoptés
en commission, ils n'ont pourtant
pas pu être débattus
pour cause de 49.3.
-Tout le chemin classique
du travail parlementaire,
je l'ai déjà fait,
j'ai même gagné, en théorie.
Les amendements ont même été votés.
Mais comme on est
dans une démocratie défaillante,
il y a eu un coup de 49.3.
Les interpellations,
je les ai faites,
les communiqués de presse,
je les ai faits,
les communications
à d'autres goûters solidaires,
je les ai faites, et même
quand on gagne, ça suffit pas.
Sanglots du bébé
Bah oui, on va aller se coucher.
Musique mélancolique
-L'hébergement d'urgence
est un dispositif
coûteux : 6 millions d'euros
sont déboursés
par l'Etat chaque jour.
Face aux besoins, le gouvernement
est passé de 120 000 places
en 2017 à 200 000 aujourd'hui,
et pourtant,
cela reste insuffisant.
...
A l'aube,
nous retrouvons l'élue
et les enfants.
-J'ai pas eu froid,
j'étais confortable,
mais j'ai beaucoup cogité,
donc j'ai eu du mal à m'endormir.
Et en fait, quand t'es sur place,
t'es obligé de réfléchir
à toutes les conséquences
que ça a sur une vie de dormir ici,
et ça nourrit encore plus la colère
et l'envie d'aller se battre.
Vous avez bien dormi ?
-Aux côtés de la députée,
Juliette,
maman et membre du collectif
Jamais sans toit.
Elle aussi aura dormi ici,
une condition exigée par la mairie
pour pouvoir occuper l'école.
Dans quelques minutes,
toute trace
du passage de la famille
aura disparu.
-La journée,
vous faites quoi ?
...
-Cette famille peut compter
sur la solidarité des citoyens
et des associations locales.
En neuf ans,
le collectif de Juliette
a mis à l'abri 634 enfants.
...
Direction
la permanence parlementaire.
Marie-Charlotte Guérin
et la bénévole
font un tour d'horizon
des prochaines actions.
-Ce qu'on fait là, on le fait pas
de gaité de coeur.
Il y a pas d'autre option
et personne d'autre ne tend la main.
Donc les autorités
se renvoient la balle.
Tant que personne réagit,
on doit faire comme ça.
-Et puisque nécessité
ne fait ici pas loi,
l'année dernière,
900 nuits solidaires
ont été offertes, 70 000 euros
ont été mis sur la table.
-Les parlementaires,
on est comme une flèche,
et l'arc qui nous propulse,
c'est la société civile :
les associations,
la mobilisation citoyenne.
Et en gros, on peut porter
tout ce qu'on veut,
si on n'a pas ce soutien
de la société civile
et des citoyens qui sont engagés
pour faire monter les sujets,
pour les mettre à l'ordre du jour,
rappeler leur importance,
la flèche, elle tombe, alors
qu'avec cet arc assez puissant,
on a une chance
d'atteindre notre cible.
-Une cible loin d'être atteinte,
même si le gouvernement
a décidé de sauver
un amendement du groupe écologiste
dans le projet de loi
de finances : 6 millions d'euros
supplémentaires, l'équivalent
de 600 places
d'hébergement d'urgence
sur la France entière.
Un combat qui se mène
dans les lignes budgétaires
mais aussi sur le terrain,
avec comme principe le système D.
Jamais sans toit
s'est battue pour ouvrir un nouveau
lieu d'hébergement d'urgence
dans cet EHPAD laissé vacant.
Grâce à la mairie,
il accueille
depuis septembre
ses premiers occupants.
-Qui dort ici ?
-Moi, ici, ma fille, là-bas,
et mon fils ici.
-Ils ont quel âge,
vos enfants ?
-Mon enfant est autiste,
il a 10 ans.
Et la fille, elle a 8 ans.
-On est dans une ancienne
chambre d'EHPAD.
Ca sent encore un tout petit peu
la naphtaline.
-C'est vrai !
-Les odeurs des EHPAD.
-Cette mère est partie du Maroc
pour une meilleure
prise en charge
de son enfant autiste.
Elle a dormi
chez des familles d'accueil,
dans des gymnases,
a connu la rue.
Aujourd'hui, elle peut souffler.
-Notre rôle,
nous, parlementaires,
mais aussi les citoyens engagés,
les collectifs, les assos,
c'est de pouvoir porter votre voix
parce que vous êtes trop occupés
à survivre, juste, à penser
à où vous allez dormir demain,
à comment nourrir vos enfants,
comment les mettre à l'école
et vous avez pas le temps
de vous battre
pour défendre vos droits.
Du coup, c'est notre responsabilité
de défendre leurs droits
et de dire qu'on peut pas vivre
dans un pays
avec autant de richesses
que le nôtre
et accepter que des gens
dorment dehors.
-On est soulagés, à l'aise,
pas de changement tout le temps.
-Vous êtes là depuis septembre ?
-Oui, septembre.
-C'est...
C'est propre, c'est en sécurité,
c'est au chaud.
-Oui, bien sûr.
-Un répit de courte durée
puisque dans moins d'un an,
elle devra quitter les lieux.
En attendant,
sans ressources, cette ancienne
comptable cherche un travail.
-Ici, pour être comptable,
c'est difficile, sans papiers.
C'est trop difficile.
On cherche partout,
même le ménage...
-Même ça, vous arrivez pas ?
-Non.
-Vous avez envie de pouvoir
gagner votre vie,
travailler, avoir une activité,
vous loger...
-Quand les enfants demandent
quelque chose,
on peut pas l'acheter.
-Oui, c'est dur.
-C'est très dur.
...
-Comme elle,
35 personnes
dont 21 enfants passeront l'hiver
dans cet hébergement d'urgence.
Lyon, comme d'autres grandes
métropoles,
a décidé d'attaquer l'Etat
pour carence dans la prise en charge
des personnes à la rue.
...
Dans son combat,
Marie-Charlotte Guérin
n'est pas seule.
A l'Assemblée,
une vingtaine de parlementaires
réfléchit à de nouvelles formes
de mobilisation pour faire
remonter la cause
dans les priorités
du gouvernement.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA